good morning everyone so we come to the
end one last lecture and puzzle today
we're going to look at a little coin
grow game and talk about obviously an
algorithm to solve the game code the
algorithm and I'm going to introduce
this notion of dynamic programming to
you which is an algorithmic technique
that's going to be useful in this game
though it's not essential to solving it
it's going to be important in improving
the efficiency of this first algorithm
that we come up with so the game itself
is very straightforward you have coins
in in a row given to you so each of
these has different values and you can
think of all of them as being positive
but it doesn't really matter and your
job is to pick coins to maximize total
value and obviously that's not very
interesting you just pick all of them if
they're all positive and if they had if
some of them happen to be negative you
wouldn't pick those so that's not
particularly interesting but it becomes
much more interesting if you add the
constraint that if you pick a coin you
can't pick the next one the immediate
next one
all right so if I pick tree I can't take
27 if I pick 14 I can't pick three but I
could pick 27 so clearly I can alternate
because I could pick skip pick skip etc
but I just can't pick pick but I could
go pick skip skip pick if I wanted a
value that corresponds to that fourth
location so there's nothing that's
stopping me from doing 14 and 4 I mean
the only thing that's stopping me from
doing that as I dropped this 27 which is
a large value and it seems like a bad
idea but on the other hand if I I mean
you can think of a different situation
where you wanted 27 and 15 and so maybe
you want to skip 4 and 5 right so what
is the maximum value for this particular
puzzle that you can come up with and
what are the coins that you would pick
in this case
somehow
56 how did you get 56 you went 14 27 and
then you went skip skip you didn't want
to pick five you could have picked five
you can't pick four but you decided that
15 was was was much better so you ended
up freaking 15 right and if in fact you
had something like eleven here so so let
me just write that first so if you did
that it's 56 and you're picking 14 27
and 15 right so so is that right
how do you get is that 56 yes that is 56
good but if I had something slightly
different someone else tell me what I
should pick here what's the maximum
value and what should I pick in terms of
coins yeah go ahead Josh
so if you go 14 27 that's 41 now you
want to pick five and so that's 46 and
then you can't pick 15 but you get to
pick 11 and so you go 50 I'm sorry 57
yeah so this one was alternation pretty
much strict alternation right so well so
you guys are getting good at this so
I'll give you a hard one
is that enough or should we go for more
all right this is the final question
final exam you got ten minutes seconds
ten seconds so Gilly I mean this is not
something you want to do manually it's
going to take a while there's a lot of
combinations here right there's a lot of
combinations here and if you do this
you're gonna go well you know you can do
it in a greedy way you can say I'll just
do alternation and so you know you go
three plus seventeen you guys gonna have
to help me here because these numbers
are gonna get large but that's 20 and
then I can't pick 23 so I go 20 plus 11
which is 31 31 plus 4 35 35 Plus 17 52
52 plus 34 I check my math please 86 86
plus 18 is 104 104 plus 12 is 116 is a
possibility but you you know at this
point you you have no idea I'd I know so
I have some idea that whether 116 is the
highest or not right and I'll tell let
you I'll tell you that it's not okay
it's not the highest you can do better
okay and you can maybe go and see if you
can twiddle things here a little bit but
remember that if you you you obviously
just don't want to drop something but if
you just drop something you want to pick
something else because if you just drop
something and you you'd lower 116 and if
you want to do better than 116 you
absolutely have to pick something up but
especially when you're alternating I
mean clearly you could have done I mean
can you do a little bit better by last
thing that I picked was 12 and because
of that I you know what happened so can
I do a little bit better than 116 yeah
by dropping 12 and grabbing 15 and I get
a plus 3 and you might think that 119 is
is the optimum but it turns out that's
not even the optimum all right and so
there's a lot of combinations and I just
looked at something local here to try
and improve things but you know maybe I
should you know 34 it's probably a was
good that I picked the 34 but I don't
really know that I mean it's possible
that if I hadn't picked the 34 that I
could have picked the 23 and the and the
17 and that is 40 right so so maybe you
know that was better right so so this is
non-trivial I mean this is a very simple
I at least to describe a puzzle but it's
non-trivial in terms of finding the
optimal
longer the row gets longer the numbers
being large is not really the issue it's
the number of numbers that's the issue
right so how are we going to solve this
of what what can we do and let's not
worry about efficiency
how could we solve this and obviously
we've been talking about recursive
algorithms and we've solved n-queens
which has lots of combinations Sudoku
even more combinations there's a lot of
combinations here but honestly the
number of combinations is dwarfed by the
number of combinations we've already
handled in these other puzzles right so
yeah so someone wants to give me some
sense of how this could be done I'd go
ahead buddy
yeah you're basically trying to trying
to create some sort of exhaustive search
what your algorithm that was iterating
over the gaps and there's many gaps by
the way you know you have a gap of one
at least and the and and another gap of
one another gap of one if I had the
strict alternation and you have to vary
you know one of the gaps to two and that
obviously impacts the numbers you picked
even for the the gap might stay the same
for the next pair of numbers but the
numbers would be shifted in the coin
draw sequence and it's fairly
complicated okay if you are willing to
give up efficiency and you have a set of
n items then how many different ways how
many different subsets of n items do I
actually have when you have n elements
you might have learned this in set
algebra but if you haven't I will will
go over it here real quick
but you know how many combinations how
many subsets do you have when you have a
set of n elements you have to count the
empty set and and the entire set right
so if I have if I have as a set of one
element then the empty set is a subset
of the one element set and then
obviously the one element set is the
subset of itself so that's two right and
then if I had two elements then you know
a and B then it's empty a B and a B
that's four
so you said get a pattern here right so
it's 2 to the N right so so if I could
generate the 2 to the n subsets that
corresponds to the N element set and
there's actually library functions in
Python power set that lets you do this
but that's cheating for this class
because you can't use libraries ok real
programmers don't use libraries that's
actually not true at all that is
probably the most dishonest statement
I've made in this course but real
programmers actually exploit libraries
but introductory programmers should
learn programming by programming from
scratch right and so but you can
generate the tutor and subsets for
example by I'm just I'm not going to I
can show you code for this offline by
running through and incrementing an
integer to go from 0 to 2 raised to n
you know so 2 raise to n could be a
million which is not that bad and then
this you could encode as you turn it
into binary so if there if n happens to
be 4 then this turns into 0 0 0 0 0 0 0
1 and each of these is a is a distinct
subset right this means none of the
elements are in there this means that
that last element is in there this means
that all 4 elements are in there and
somewhere in here if you have something
like this the second one is in there and
the fourth one is in there right so you
could essentially use iteration to
generate all of the subsets and that
you're not done yet what do you have to
do now now that I've given you all the
subsets it's to three lines of code to
solve our problem someone tell me what
those two three lines of code are from a
standpoint of operations required right
I'm now looking at each of the subsets
what do I need to do for a given subset
yeah go ahead right
all right that's right I could iterate
through the subset and find the sum of
second plus fourth I do that for you I
do I do that for all the subsets or and
and pick the maximum or do I do that for
a subset of the subsets and pick the
maximum well what happens with this one
this is picking every every number so I
mean this is obviously gonna be bigger
than all of the other ones
so did I have to enumerate all of them
what what is what is wrong with this
picture here what is wrong with what I
just said what is someone other than
cannot row what is wrong with with this
with this solution which picks all the
numbers it's on the it's on the board
the answer is on the board
yeah go ahead Ryan constraint so not all
of the subsets I mean if all of the
subsets work then you don't have to
enumerate all the subsets you would just
pick the numbers all the numbers right
so so you have to now check that and
that is that is some code so I lied I
guess I I mean I mean we're not finished
with my dishonesty but it's not to three
lines of code it's a little bit more
than that to check that a particular
subset whether it violates the
constraints or not right and so you
never see and so what is the check I
mean so it's gonna be four or five lines
of code what is the simple check if I
give you a bit string what is the simple
check that you need to perform in order
to check the violation of the constraint
in terms of zeros and ones yeah I go
ahead yeah you have not two consecutive
once right if you ever see two or more
consecutive ones you got a problem right
so that's that's easy to check and this
constraint is no two consecutive ones
okay so you can imagine coding this up
and if you coded that strategy up it
turns out that this particular thing I
it's a it's reasonable strategy if n is
small and it turns out that it would
tell you that you want to pick 1523 for
interesting enough 17:34 so double skip
over there because you would really
wanted to get to 17 this 34 and 18 and
you want 15 that makes sense you don't
want 12 and so this ends up adding up to
126 which happens to be the optimal okay
so you can you can certainly do that you
can as I said use the power set to save
yourself some trouble but you still have
to code the violation of constraints
right we want to do substantially better
than this because if n happens to be a
52 raised to 50 is way too large a
number and we don't want to be
enumerated all of these subsets in fact
there's a way of doing this in certainly
in polynomial time and it's going to be
at something where we're going to be
able to run this this algorithm in
linear time we can kind of make a pass
through this list and get that 126
number blazingly fast okay using the
notion of memorization and dynamic which
is related to dynamic programming and so
this is a powerful algorithmic technique
that you'll see over and over especially
if you take classes like double O six
and or four six that gives you
exponential improvements in run time
rather than 2 raise to n a growing as 2
raise to n you grow as n ok [ __ ] is a
huge difference obviously now usually
when we talk about dynamic programming
be the star
with the recursive strategy not this
enumerative subset strategy to generate
the different solutions and one of the
problems with this is you're generating
a lot of solution a lot of incorrect
invalid subsets right because one one
one one is an invalid subset and there's
a lot of them that are invalid a a
better approach which it would still be
exponential but it's better then in
terms of numbers then to raise to n is
to only generate recursively the legal
combinations and then pick the best
legal combination and the legal
combination of course in this case as we
described was no two consecutive ones
right and so now we've done recursion
we've looked at recursive code so the
key thing when you write recursive code
is remember you want to I get
subproblems that looked like the problem
that you're solving right they look
exactly like the problem you're solving
because then you can invoke yourself as
a procedure with different arguments
right and we kind of went through this a
couple of times right so this problem is
actually is less complicated than the
tiling problem it's basically a row of
numbers and you you're going to have
let's just say you have numbers a b c d
e f try to think of a recursive strategy
that says i want you know let's call it
coin row and coin row is going to have a
through f as an argument that's the list
I'm just using pseudocode here and I
want coin row to do some computation and
it's going to call coined row maybe
multiple times but the key thing is
what are the arguments that you have
inside of those recursive calls for
Cointreau and that's the biggest
question the easier question to answer
is what happens when you have the base
case and you you end up essentially
saying you got one coin on the row so
you got a one coin problem right what
happens then what is the base case what
do you do you pick the coin okay because
if you had two of them if you happen to
choose the base case to be two
and in this case E and F what would you
do in that case compare the two and pick
the bigger one right but you have to be
a little bit careful here because when
you make the recursive calls obviously
you can't have I would this work you if
you pick a if I did something like this
I do a plus coin row so inside here I do
a plus coined row B through F if I wrote
this code as a plus coin row B through F
what would happen
whatever happened if I had coin row and
then I said I'm going to return a plus
coin row B through F and then I have a
base case that says that if I have a
single I still need a base case this is
just the recursive step I need a base
case so this would complete and then I
say that if I ever have an argument of
length one I'm going to return that
argument all right so what would happen
with this code any ideas
go ahead kai
if you pick all the coins it would just
totally pick all the coins because it
would go a plus and then it go B through
F the constraint hasn't been encoded in
here right so we would just pick all the
coins right so that doesn't make sense
right
so I have to I haven't I have some
choices here and so this was a it was a
giveaway that this would not work
because it's not doing any choices I
mean it's just picking all the coins
right so what happens if I pick a what
what does it mean if I pick a what does
that mean
what does that mean to my value I that I
want to return which is that which
eventually needs to be the maximum value
and what does it mean with respect to I
the subproblems right so the first
question is easier what does it mean
with respect to my value I need to add
it to the value right okay what the
second question is what happens to the
if I pick a what happens to the coin
draw problem that remains what can I say
about the coin draw problem that remains
that's going to tell me about if I
picked a so this might be pick the first
one pick first in this case which is
which is a I'll just put that in
brackets so what what do I need to send
as an argument to coin row as is as one
possibility what do I need to send as an
argument to coin row right someone who
hasn't answered this should use the
constraint use the constraint what do I
need to send is a argument to coin row
yeah go ahead I saw a cry first
but C through F exactly I cannot pick D
right so so I encode the constraint in
the recursive call by saying that if I
picked a then I encode this as C dot a
dot F okay I'll just say C - f right and
let me go ahead and raise this to give
myself a little bit more room but I'm
not done yet so
that if I ended up taking a and I go if
I don't write any more code and I end up
picking up a plus the value that I get
from coin row C through F and if I don't
write any more code what does that
correspond to in terms of an algorithm
we've actually used that algorithm what
does that correspond to if I only make
one recursive call and and I and I pick
a and I go see through F what does that
correspond to with respect to an
algorithm so on someone who has an
answer this is your last chance
that's lecture right yep you're thinking
about it
go ahead right so Sally on E
right so Johnny says and you know
basically it's an alternation algorithm
right you know you're going to end up
picking a and then C and then E and then
air I'm that you can't pick F because
you had to skip F so it's also nation
right I mean we did this alternation
algorithm we said if we knew it wasn't
going to be optimal so it clearly it's
not a solution to our problem
algorithmically speaking because they're
only going to give you the alternating
coins and that might work out but it
didn't work out in the case of our
longer problem right we got the what was
it 116 right so so that doesn't work but
so what what what else do I do what is
the other case that corresponds to what
I have here I can pick the coin and I
could skip the coin right I could pick
the coin and I could skip the gun skip
first a aha what now can I pass into the
coin draw argument what can I pass into
the coin draw argument if I skip a go
ahead right D through F exactly so it's
different P through F right that's it
that's around with them all right this
is now four lines of code in terms of
recursive calls okay one last thing I
did these two things
I'm gonna get values back for each of
these because I'm gonna get a value back
it's you know that's essentially what
I'm doing but I'm picking I'm going to
add the value a and then I'm going to
add it to the return value corresponding
to coin row seed through F and then in
this case I'm gonna get simply the value
corresponding to B through F what do I
do with rel one and Val - what do I do
with these two values do I look at them
do I
yeah what what is the value for the
original what is the value that I want
to return for the original problem just
like with all of the things we've done
we've taken values of sub of subproblems
solutions to subproblems and we've
actually done something with them to
return the value or solution for the
original problem so what do I need to do
what line of code do I need to write to
return a value for the original coin
draw problem that had eight through F as
its arguments it's one line of code what
is that line of code right go ahead Josh
return the max that's exactly right
you return max well one well - all right
and so let me show you the code for that
alright so this is a little bit better
than the subset solution that we
described but as it turns out it's not a
whole lot better and we'll talk about
that but this code now should not be
surprising to you right because we
talked about it and effectively
collectively we wrote it right that was
there was a collective coding exercise
called cooperative coding not really but
close enough and so you see what I have
up there and there's there's only one
thing that I didn't describe to you
which
is something that I'm gonna get to in a
second but you see something called
table in there which is essentially
something that keeps the the maximum
value corresponding to the smaller
problems that we're looking at right so
it keeps keeps that around and so but
you can see that there's a base case if
you forget a table I and this reason the
table is in there and I'm gonna ask you
why in a minute but forget about table
for a second if Len is 0 you're gonna
return 0 that's a base case if Len is 1
you're going to return that coin that's
also another base case and you might you
know end up with one or the other
because obviously you're skipping coins
right so it's possible that you you need
to need to take into account both of
these base cases you say what do I need
to base cases well you're taking away
coins so you might end up with something
that's empty right so you need both of
those base cases and then pick equals
coin road a table this thing over here
is is picking the coin and then 2 : says
that you're dropping the in in in our
case we picked a we would drop B and
start with C and skip is your skipping
it so you just skipped it and you go row
1 : makes perfect sense right and I
don't know if you guys have ever
returned you I think you have in
exercises if you return multiple values
in in the return statement and so this
thing over here is the 0 says that I'm
gonna look at at the first value not the
table because that's a value and I'm
gonna add two values up and I'm only
concerned with this value here but I'm
actually returning this table thing and
this table thing as you can see from
here is simply computing the optimum
values that correspond to problems of of
the entire problem and essentially the
problems that are there are smaller and
so when we end up you're skipping from
the beginning and so when you look at
the
Landro -1 that is effectively since
you're going to in the beginning of the
list that is telling you what the
optimum is
Landro - 130 Landro minus 1 i yeah
that's right
Landro the the number of entries in the
table is is len row plus 1 the total
number of entries in the table is is
starts with 0 always so it's land row
plus 1 and so table rent land row is
there is the entirety that's what you
want for the original thing and len row
minus 1 looks at an optimum for that
skipping the first one and and so on
right so you're skipping from the
beginning so remember that why do you
think we have this table in here if
you're only concerned with with the
maximum value are are we only concerned
with the maximum value what did i do
when i when i got these numbers up what
else did I do other than pointing out
these numbers I also gave you more
information right right I mean I just
said 120 see if I just told you 126 what
would you believe me well you I mean
it's very hard to check I mean I it made
it was it was credible because I said
126 and then I told you by circling them
what the numbers were right so if you
don't have this table stuff in here it
turns out that you can actually you
don't have enough information to figure
out what coins were picked right you'll
get the correct answer
I mean it's guaranteed to be correct
answer but you don't have the
information about 1523 skipping 11 and 3
and getting 4 and so on and so forth
right so we need other more code that
takes this collection of subproblems
that each have been solved so if you
actually solved all of the subproblems
corresponding to picking this and
picking that and then picking this and
so on and so forth and you need to use
those values in order to discover using
a traceback
procedure what what the coins are or you
could do more work in here I chose to
you'll see why I chose to do it this way
where I'm collecting up everything into
table
and I'm going to eventually and we'll
talk about this code if at least briefly
but this code trace back is taking the
original problem and a table and it's
just iteratively going through there's
no enumeration here this is very
efficient it's iteratively going through
row and table and discovering what the
selected coins are okay and so that's
that's something that we look at and in
just a minute actually not just a minute
but after we go back to this and and I'm
gonna tell you or ask you about this in
terms of its computational complexity
okay so anyway so assume that we've done
trace back and it's not hard to do if
you have the table of results then let's
go back to this and let's talk about the
recursive calls and let's take a look at
what's going on here with respect to how
many recursive calls are made and then
we'll get to memorization and dynamic
programming so let me just say if I had
coins that this is the number of
elephants so I have five then I'm going
to you know call coins for and I'm gonna
call coins three and so I'm here I
skipped the first one here I picked the
first one and therefore I had to skip
the second one so I have three here
right that makes sense and then over
here what what can i what any what do I
need to write here if I follow exactly
the pattern I'm gonna write coins three
right so I have coins three over here
and here it's coins two and here I'm
just going to write the numbers down to
one and
again I got two one
and so on now the the base case might
you might keep going you know even after
two because the base cases are you go
one zero one zero right what do you see
in here that's a little bothersome what
do you see here that's bothersome what
is that
symbolically if I had some number of
elements and elements what I put here
it's n right and what do you see here
it's getting very pretty big getting
pretty big so down here is getting
pretty big right so that's the problem
right and one of the reasons is getting
pretty big is because you're doing work
over and over
you see coins three here a couple of
places points to in three places
and if this were larger you see a lot of
sub problems being solved over and over
so this code that you see up on the
screen is include incredibly inefficient
because it's solving the same problem
over and over okay
in particular if you had-even would
solve coins for exactly once but coins
three twice coins two three times and if
I just sort of went up and made this 10
coins ten then you would see things that
are solved tens of times and eventually
you'll see things that are solved
hundreds of times okay you're just
repeating work over and over you can
actually write a recurrence relationship
that says that if you had an n-element
coin row problem then your recurrence is
your the recurrence corresponds to the
number of calls that are made number of
operations therefore that are performed
as a n equals n minus 1 plus a and minus
2 and then the base cases are you know a
0 equals 1 and a 1 equals 1 because it's
just picking that and so if you look at
what a 2 would be a 2 is 2
but then a 3 is 2 plus it initially it
grows fairly slowly but then when you
get to a 4 it becomes 5 and so on and at
people see this number have you seen
this number before this recurrence
relationship before is called Fibonacci
right it's called the Fibonacci
recurrence and this this actually shows
up here so this has a relationship to
Fibonacci and it's the number of
computations in a recursive Fibonacci is
exactly the same as as in this problem
but if I told you to compute the
Fibonacci number F of n can you do that
quickly I mean you just do that if I
wanted to just for you to compute the
Fibonacci number and then you just do
that iteratively like I'm doing here
right the numbers would get bigger but
there's no reason to do exponential work
for Fibonacci right but here of course
we're doing something much more
sophisticated than just a Fibonacci in
the sense that we're working with the
coin draw problem but this should give
you a sense of of the efficiency that is
possible here by thinking about the
relationship between recursive Fibonacci
that would look a lot like the structure
that you see here
you know just calling fib of a a of n I
and a fib of sorry for fib of n you're
calling fib of n minus 1 and you're
calling fib of n plus n minus 2
recursively you're adding them up and
the base cases are exactly the same as
you have here returning to 0 or 0 case F
0 you're returning one and so on and so
forth and even Funaki would you end up
having redundancy in the recursive
formulation which is exactly the
redundancy that you see here ok and so
basically it turns out that
if you want to go exponential to linear
and you kind of see where this is going
the recursive was exponential at the
iterative in the case of Fibonacci is
linear so two things I won you can take
this and you can turn it into iteration
and make it linear but you know that is
actually a more dramatic transformation
of the code you can do something that is
equivalent in efficiency to the
iterative version both for Fibonacci and
for our coin draw problem and we'll do
it for our coin draw a problem that
corresponds to as I said a more local
modification of this code at that
eliminates redundancy that eliminates
redundant computations okay and all of
these things are equivalent and they're
all part of dynamic programming and you
know if we have four lectures on dynamic
programming in double oh six so in ten
minutes or fifteen minutes you're just
going to get some sense for what this is
all about okay and so this is really a
preview or an elevator pitch
perhaps a trailer right so you end up
essentially doing equivalent work in the
recursive memorized version of this code
that I'll show you in just a minute
that adds three lines occurred to this
and makes the complexity go from
exponential to linear and all you do in
this code that makes this complexity
equivalent to the iterative and you know
that's very efficient is you remember
the results you memorize the results of
the computation and you remember that
you've solved coins for which doesn't
really help you in this particular
instance but you remember that you've
solved coins three and so you don't end
up doing all of this work you end up
kind of just saying okay I mean depends
on I'm sorry
depends on on which direction you went
let's say that you for argument's sake
that you went in this in this direction
first okay it totally depends on which
direction you went first and since I
drew this out and I don't want to change
it
let's just assume that you went in in
terms of points three first which in
fact is correct in terms of the code
because if you see what I have there I
went in the pig Direction first which
meant that I would go ahead and pick
that that first value and then I'd go in
in the right direction okay the right
hand side direction so if I did all of
that I did all I do all of this work
now there's also memorization going on
inside of here so it's not like I'm
doing all of this work I'm not only
getting it just a factor too in terms of
improvement but definitely once I do
this and I get the value I can just
return that value here and I don't have
to do all the work underneath this
that's why I put this in a square okay
and it remembers that this is being done
recursively okay so I'm gonna do it for
coins too and so if I had multiple coins
Stu's then you know I won't have to do
that and then over here if I had a
longer coin draw problem to begin with
there's a lot of memorization that goes
on right and you end up only solving
this is the key you end up only solving
each sub-problem how many times once now
the aha moment how many subproblems are
there how many coin draw problems are
there given an n-element coin draw
problem how many all of you together how
many coins or problems are there and
that's it there's only n coin draw
problems okay it's like you had a
through F he had B through F yet C
through a few D through F yet EF and F
so if you only solve a coin draw problem
once and there's only n coin draw
problems the complexity clearly cannot
be exponential it's going to be linear
because whatever work you did for that
problem is all that you have to do and
so maybe there's a constant factor but
let's say that the number of operations
obviously there's
- max I mean it's not complicated we
know what that is right so it would be
the complexity of solving a subproblem
times the number of subproblems the
complexity of solving a subproblem is
constant you know it's just a small
number of operations and the number of
subproblems is is linear so it's linear
time which is exactly the same as the
iterative version okay
this is an incredibly powerful notion
you know which is why there's classes on
this topic right just this very topic
and we spend a lot of time on this in
double-o six as well as so four six so
what I'm going to do for the the main
thing I want to do is show you this code
that is an incremental modification of
the code I showed you before that takes
this complexity and turns it from
exponential to linear right using this
notion of memorization and then I want
to tell you a little bit about the
traceback code because that's
interesting but from a standpoint of
just getting the value back you're all
good right with or even understanding
trace back so all I've done here is
taken table and I've turned it into a
dictionary okay and I have to do a
little bit of work here with respect to
the memorization right so so if you if I
look at the base cases it's pretty much
exactly the same I just have a memo
instead of table and all of these are
are essentially the same I'm sorry all
of these up here are essentially the
same and then I'm looking at but I'm
looking at a particular problem I'm I
see whether the memo table that I have
if Len row in memo then if it's in the
dictionary that means I've already seen
this problem before and I just return
the the values stored in that dictionary
and the value stored in the dictionary
is is essentially a pair which
corresponds to
not just the value of the problem but
also I'm storing I'm sorry I take that
back
so memo itself is just like table this
this is just this memo here is simply
because overall I want to return both
the value and the memo table okay so
this memo table is exactly like the
original table it's simply a set of key
value pairs that go a memo five you know
equals 56 memo for maybe equals 42 etc
so that's just that's just a simple memo
table and I just need to return the memo
and so that's why I had this memo out
here and this looks exactly the same as
it did before these three lines are
exactly the same this is an important
line right so these lines were added
because I wanted memo eyes and look up
what I solved before and this line was
added it well added in the sense that it
was added for memo but I already had it
for table so it's just a simple
replacement so perhaps I should have
said added but this is important because
I'm I'm putting it into the memo table
and and really it's really this if
statement that's the key
I don't do redundant work so if you get
to the safe statement you're obviously
getting to a return which means you're
not making these recursive calls which
is exactly going over here and
remembering that you solve coins three
and returning the value of coins three
the moment you see it alright that makes
sense everybody's good with that
excellent let's just run this and I want
to show you what this gives you just so
you get some sense with what's going on
you're getting up there's a couple of
different problems and I'm running them
I with a different code and so you're
getting the same answers that's just for
verification purposes so if you focus in
on on what what happens here this is
essentially solving our first smaller
problem and it's telling you that if you
have the entire problem with the seven
coins which is what I have up there
the first problem here
then what you have is 56 and if in fact
you ended up dropping you're looking at
the subproblem that goes from 3 to 1 and
you drop 14 the optimum value for that
is 42 okay and then if you drop both 14
and 3 and you went with that then the
you need to go backwards from here 56:42
and it's still 42 and even if you so if
you drop 14 it's 42
if you drop 3 it's still 42 because 27
and 15 you know give you your 42 and
that makes sense and so you can see that
right and then this other thing here is
the bigger problem it says table equals
sorry yikes Python shell let me just
point with the cursor this large thing
here is our bigger problem and you can
see the table for this 126 if you drop
the first one you still get 126 but then
if we drop the first 2 3 and 15 you get
obviously a smaller result and so on and
so forth and this table that I'm getting
back which is basically the original
table that could you think of as a list
that turned into a dictionary when I
wanted to memorize because I want to
look it up very efficiently I could have
left it in this case I'm as a Python
list I did not need to use a dictionary
because I can always I didn't need the
generality of a dictionary where the
indices to a list can be strings or
negative numbers right I mean I'm just
indexing into this so the dictionary is
a it's a bit of a red herring I just
happen to use it in general you use
dictionaries because you may have to
look up things that are more complicated
than just integer values but here I
could just number the subproblems 0
through 7 what have you and then just
look it up right
so the bottom line is I need that
information in order to compute or
figure out what coins were selected and
so that last thing that I will show you
is the trace back routine which I just
put up there briefly but I just want to
spend one minute on this and we will
close and this trace back routine is
taking the values that you saw and
figuring out whether you picked a coin
or not so what it does is it looks at
the entire thing and it knows that the
the entire thing is 56 and then it says
if I drop the first one and I get 42
right and it compares 56 Evette 42 and
says wait a minute the difference there
is 14 and that is exactly the the value
of the first element right so what this
tells me is that if I had the original
problem
I got 56 if I drop the first one I get
42 right foot as optimal so that implies
that for the original problem I picked
the first coin okay because 56-42 is 14
that's it that's pretty much all you
have to do you just have to do that over
and over and it's a little bit more
complicated than that only because you
don't want to get into negative indices
for tables and so the only reason that
first line table renderer - I equals
equals Rho I is there is for the corner
case where you have a single element
list and you don't want to get into a
situation where this thing here cannot
be negative if this is negative then the
program crashes so you don't want to get
to this statement it becomes negative
when it's a degenerate case and you
don't want to get there this or takes
care of that you essentially check for
the singleton equality and then you
don't fall through the second if this
part of the statement is true then this
doesn't get computed so if table land
row I equals equals Rho I is true then
you don't compute that you don't get a
negative index and everything works out
right but it comes down to 56-42 is 14
and you're all good to go
all right good all right so that's all I
have
well for this lecture for the class I'm
gonna be collecting six double oh six
next semester I noticed that some of you
were pre registered so I guess it's not
goodbye but it doesn't have to be
goodbye for the rest of you you know
where I said happy to talk algorithms
and computer science thanks for being an
attentive audience
[Applause]